[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hi everybody and welcome to the Day of
the Dead digital showcase thanks to Jeff
Keeley for having us be part of his
Summer Games Fest and thank you to all
of you the millions of people watching
out millions of people God that can't be
right
this thing is really grown since it
started 10 years ago here in San
Francisco day of the devs was a idea
from double flight Productions and the
friends that I am a bit to put on a show
that really celebrated video games and
focused on the fans and the developers
and brought them together to meet and
celebrate games it started as a live
event here in San Francisco where we had
developers showing their games where
people could play them and also listen
to music and eat food and drink and it
was really just a festival of amazing
creativity and a very inspiring event
and then during the pandemic it became
digital only and now we're doing both a
live event and a digital showcase so
people from around the world can enjoy
all of these amazing games we had record
number of submissions this year more
people wanted to be part of day of the
doves than any year previously and we
have more World premieres today than
ever before I'm excited I hope you're
excited and please without further Ado
enjoy day of the devs
digital showcase
there'll be a facts on that it's
something good
I am pleased to introduce a brand new
game from a team that is near and dear
to my heart this is from Greg lobenov
and the team at wishes unlimited who
made incredible games like wander song
and chicory here's their new title
Beastie ball
foreign
bouncing off the walls excited to
finally tell you what my friends and I
have been working on together ever since
chicory came out a couple years ago
introducing
Beastie ball
[Music]
Beastie ball is a turn-based RPG where
you coach a team of beasties to play
Beastie ball which is kind of like
volleyball you play as customizable
coach character and you can explore this
huge open world recruiting all kinds of
BCS to your team
then you can challenge Rival Sports
Teams as you rise your way through the
Beastie ball rankings
[Music]
feasties are highly social creatures
that evolve to play sports and their
natural wild state they're constantly
playing Beastie ball to build
friendships to sell disputes or just to
have fun when VCS play together they
actually become friends with one another
and depending on their personalities and
their teamwork style they can form
different kinds of friendships
but whether they become besties or
rivals or Partners or sweethearts
they'll get some kind of unique combo
ability that only that pair of beasties
can do which can turn the tide in a
really tough match
[Music]
between their own thing making their own
decisions they'll only join your team
after being convinced by you fulfilling
a certain set of conditions while you're
playing against them the goal isn't to
collect as many VCS as you can but to
spend time with the ones that you care
about and be surprised by the ways that
they grow and change and the bonds that
they form with each other
[Music]
we knew we wanted to create a really
wide variety of beasties that each have
their own ecological niche and way of
playing Beastie ball so we're working
with a really wonderful bunch of concept
artists and spending a lot of time on
each design all VCS have a range of
colors and sizes and their poses and
animations are all hand drawn which
gives us lots of opportunity to express
their personalities and their different
ways of moving to help give each BC that
personality we've been doing unique
voices for them each one can express a
range of emotions and we've had a lot of
fun performing that but it's not all
just friendships and rainbows this game
is about sports you come from a Tiny
Town built around a nature preserve
they're kind of underdogs until one day
when the Beastie ball leak shows up and
starts tearing down the preserve to
build a stadium your only way to stop
the construction is to rise all the way
to the top of the Beastie ball league
right from the start of your adventure
you'll be able to see all the ranked
teams on your map you decide where to go
who to challenge in what order and every
time you defeat a ranked coach the other
ranked coaches become stronger so no
matter which way you go you'll have a
tough and exciting rise to the top we're
so excited to finally reveal this it's a
really special project for us and if
Beastie ball looks cool to you too then
please check us out at
beastieballgame.com we're going to be
reviewing a crowdfunding campaign very
very soon and we'd love to have your
support thanks very much we can't wait
to talk to you more about Beastie ball
foreign
breaker heart machine's follow-up title
in the Hyperlite Universe you'll assume
the role of a mercenary with some
serious skills you'll be entering the
overgrowth an amazing open world with
everything from Lush Rolling Hills to
deep labyrinths they'll be comprised of
both handcrafted and procedural elements
just how I like my levels like its
predecessor it'll be chock full of
secrets and lore sure to satisfy even
the most curious Explorer you'll face
off against enigmatic enemies armed with
an arsenal of weapons that you've
crafted with The Spoils of your previous
battles and for those Die Hard fans that
have been eagerly awaiting its release
we have some never before seen sneak
peeks
this is hyper light breaker hello I'm
Alex creative director at heart machine
and we're making hyper light breaker
[Music]
hyper light breaker is a huge stylish
bloody game as is our ammo it's a game
that's Vivid but Bleak with a crumbling
world that can be brutal and beautiful
all at once
it's a major landmark for us and the
first of its kind an open world game
where you never return to the same world
twice
I'd say it's a mix of incredible open
world games like breath of the wild
distilled into the format of a roguelike
such as dead cells or hands
play alone or with friends cooperatively
online
breaker's narrative will be presented
fully through Visual storytelling where
you'll discover and decipher the mystery
of this world and lost land from long
ago
every world will be different loaded
dangerous creatures razor sharp combat
vast overgrown Wilderness long dead
civilizations and new discoveries in a
mysterious vibrant and horribly ominous
atmosphere
each biome in the world is different
with unique dangers set pieces and
stories of their own there will be
massive bosses to take down in an open
structure with dangerous unique and
challenging sub bosses scattered
throughout runs
you'll pick up new gear make new builds
unlock new characters upgrade your
equipment as you bring back more and
more materials from runs
we've learned so much from our previous
games building up amazing Tech and a
deep well of knowledge and experience as
a team breaker is a culmination of all
that incredible work
excited to have you experience it for
yourself
we'll have a lot more information on the
game as we come closer and closer to
Early Access later this year
and now in true day of the devs fashion
we're traveling Halfway Around the Globe
to Transylvania to bring you a game that
is not what you expect
from developer Stone Skip and publisher
I am 8bit presents I'm thrilled to bring
you a world premier title that is not
only relaxing and enjoyable it's chill
and vibey let that anxiety go while you
play simpler times
hi there welcome I'm Lara and I'm
dragosh of stone skip Studio we are a
small team from Transylvania and our
mission is to create meaningful
interactive experiences our first game
simpler times sheds light to the beauty
of the ordinary and serves as a place
from the past where it can be present
simpler times follow Style on a
heartwarming journey through her
memories as she prepares to leave her
childhood home
it's getting pretty full starting to
feel like I'm never gonna come back
we want you to slow down and Savor the
Present Moment by immersing you in
China's world
it's apple picking season my favorite
through Visual storytelling and mindful
interactions you will Journey alongside
her as she delves into her past and
uncovers her authentic self
with each puzzle Dinah grows closer to
adulthood and you'll be there to guide
her from simple activities like picking
dried leaves from a plant to more
complex ones like building a birdhouse
you'll interact with objects that hold
sentimental value for time
I really wish I could say
yes or Duets together
[Music]
we live in it too we wanted to create a
space where players can take a break
slow down and enjoy something meaningful
foreign
stems from Stories We Believe need to be
told and heard inspired by this very
place we're now sitting in the game is a
reflection of the physical spaces
Western timing and The Memories We Hold
there
I've spent so much time here looking out
the window it's hard to believe that I
won't see this view for a while
we want to build a sense of awareness
and appreciation for the world around us
encouraging you to reflect on your own
memories and experiences
simpler times is coming soon on PC and
other platforms so make sure to wish
list on Steam and follow us on social
media thanks for taking the time to
listen we hope
we hope bye it's like childhood is the
beach and growing up is the sea
can I still take all these seashells
with me can I lock them in a chest with
my memories
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this next game is from sad owl Studios
and thunderflublishing it's a really
unique puzzle game built around a camera
mechanic where the photos that you take
become 3D worlds to explore this is
viewfinder
[Music]
viewfinder is a difficult game to
describe in words but if you saw it
you'd immediately recognize it
it is a game that you know gives players
a lot of freedom
what's an old photograph doing here
take photos or find photos and then make
them into real 3D spaces
did
what makes it unique is the central
mechanic where you're using a camera and
pictures to reshape and reconfigure the
world around you in order to solve
challenges in creative ways
it's such a unique experience and I
think everybody is just going to have a
different experience of how they play
viewfinder and that's just a really nice
thing to it
perfect fit
an elegant solution
hmm that doesn't look right
you can rotate reality too
if I was to compare viewfinder to other
games I'd say it's like the gameplay of
portal combined with the visual
illusions of super liminal or ant
chamber people have also compared it to
the witness and manifold garden and
various other third person puzzle games
it's a puzzle game but it's very
sandboxy and playful and open-ended
the whole concept of when we started is
that when you actually create something
you do destroy a lot of things and you
know that's just a very important lesson
in creation
viewfinder is created by different
people and you know we have people from
all over the world who have such a
diverse and interesting cultures
each character comes from a different
culture this is where there's a lot of
sort of culture specific props and items
and themes who you learn about most
through environments and environmental
storytelling
so we've tried to sort of make these
special spaces that really represent
that character who they are what they
like to do I'm sure you noticed by now
but using film was always mirin's idea
one of her many Passions
Celia was always fond of games
it's just very important for us to just
put in what we know so that the rest of
the world could also you know have a
glimpse of the experiences that we've
had
this must be the next stage
let's go
[Music]
we received a record number of
submissions for this summer game Fest
edition of day of the devs but this next
game didn't actually come through that
process we have eyes everywhere and the
curation team is always looking for
games this next one actually came from
Twitter because the Creator was posting
all these amazing gifts and we reached
out via DM and and asked if we could
feature the game uh so here it is this
beautiful gorgeous hand-drawn ghost
story called haunting
hello everyone my name is Leo dasso and
I'm with moon Loop together we're making
a game called Hunty
[Music]
the main mechanic in haunty is that as a
ghost you can hunt things and get access
to their abilities
it's a big variety of things that you
can hunt in this game
I think you'll have a lot of fun sort of
exploring around and seeing what
different things you can haunt and the
abilities that they give you
core mechanics resemble very much a twin
stick shooter however unlike twin stick
Shooters it focuses Less on the high
intensity moments and more on finding
creative ways to use the twin stick
Paradigm to create fun solutions to the
challenges in the game
haunty follows the story of a ghost in
the afterlife and beyond that it really
expands into a lot of ghosts in the
afterlife and sort of the stories that
they have
foreign
[Music]
the progression and story of Hunty both
center around collecting these stars and
the stars have this special ability that
they give ghosts access to pieces of
their past life that they've left behind
the environments and characters are all
carefully crafted with a 2d hand-drawn
style so there's a lot of painstaking
frame by frame animation work in there
and we have a fantastic soundtrack
[Music]
so it all sort of comes together to give
you this sort of tour through the
afterlife chilled out experience
[Music]
if this is something you're interested
in be sure to wish list it
helps us out a lot
our next game is a bit of a blast from
the past
it arrived on the scene around 12 years
ago quickly became the Talk of the Town
and won a handful of awards including
the Seamus McNally grand prize at gdc's
independent games Festival but then
shortly afterwards both the game and its
creator vanished that game was cartlife
a slice of life simulation game that put
you in the shoes of various Street
vendors and tossed you with setting up a
successful business selling bagels or
newspapers
story unfolds you'd soon find yourself
making tough choices and trying to
balance keeping your business afloat
with the needs of your character and
their families it was a truly unique
powerful and special game and it's super
sad that it's been unplayable now for
the better part of a decade but it gives
me great pleasure to tell you that
lovely restored and better than ever
cart life is back
foreign
hi I'm Nick Herman I'm with ad hoc
studio and we're here to show you cart
life
car life is a retail simulator developed
by Richard Hoffmeyer and was originally
released in 2013 where it won a bunch of
awards at the independent games festival
for a variety of reasons he ended up
pulling it off steam but all of us at ad
hoc are such big fans of Richard's work
now we're partnering with him to help
bring it back
[Music]
thank you
in car life you can play as three
different characters in any Order each
have their own unique background and
circumstances but what they all have in
common is that they're trying to make it
as Street vendors
Melanie is a recently divorced mother
and has moved back into her family home
with her daughter all the while trying
to establish her new coffee cart
[Music]
Andrus is a Ukrainian immigrant who is
trying to put down roots in a new town
by opening a newspaper stand
and Vinnie has big dreams but never
enough money to make it happen he's
hoping that selling his homemade Bagels
will help turn things around for him
managing your own cart is not an easy
job just like in real life in cart life
your resources are limited
you need to take care of yourself and
others and how you prioritize the needs
of your cart against the personal needs
of each character will determine the
outcome of their stories
[Music]
the world of cart life is alive and
filled with characters who are potential
customers that you'll get to know as you
try to build your business
there's no right or wrong way to play
this game what players choose to do with
the time that they have with each
character is entirely up to them
everyone's experience will be different
based on the choices they make and what
they prioritize and even the order in
which they choose to play the characters
this release is going to have a bunch of
new story content new art updated
controls and mechanics and we really
look forward to sharing it all with you
on PC and console later this year
thank you
the skateboard Renaissance has been
going on for the last couple years in
games and as we get deeper into the
grind Revival things are getting a
little more avant-garde and daring this
next one gives you all that Tony Hawk
mechanical goodness that you crave but
with the heavy helping of demons and
brimstone this is the world premiere of
hellscape
hello my name is Jordy vonenbosa also
known as kwebbelkop I'm the CEO and
founder of phantom coast and today we'll
be talking about hellscape foreign
[Music]
first try here we go
no that was a good combo
all right that's it
again
LK takes place in convert times here you
play as Anthony Falcon a skater through
and through All Anson wants to do escape
and spare times Fable Beach even if that
means he has to go through the Gods and
Monsters who will do anything to stop
him and his skater friends from doing
what they love most
skateboard mechanics are very similar to
the arcade-like games such as Tony Hawk
Pro Skater I mean our lead game designer
Steve actually works on Tony Hawk's
Underground it started a long time ago
the idea and the far off far-flonging
land of 2002 I worked on a game called
Tony Hawk Underground and at the time we
were working on it we were thinking man
this really looks a lot like an RPG or
an action RPG you have all these stats
and you're upgrading and all this kind
of stuff it's super cool super neat
right but of course we're bound to Tony
Hawk we're bound to the real Pro skaters
it always seemed to me that the skate
Graphics create and imply such an
interesting world but it's not a
coherent world that you can visit so
that was one of the motivations behind
hellscape Hells Gate is a skateboarding
roguelike game it fuses together old
school skateboarding with the tricks and
traversal manuals grinds jumps bounce
meters with roguelite structure
just like with other games in the
roguelite genre death is a central
mechanic in the game
when you die in a run thankfully you
don't lose everything you keep your
resources which you can use to get
permanent upgrades such as tattoos or
skateboards which act as weapons
a combat inner game can be described as
a fast-paced skateboard Hack and Slash
while you have your light and heavy
attacks the core of the gameplay
revolves around your skateboarding
tricks the game should be quite easy for
people to pick up and play it has a
combat system which is meant to be very
friendly very forgiving and rewarding
especially at the beginning and then
gradually it teaches you and ramps up
the skill of skateboarding where you
need it when you need it
thank you
why did you stop me from skating look at
yourself your wing your arm what do you
think happens when that gets to your
head
thank you for watching this reveal of
hellscape which listing the game would
mean the world to us thank you
in our next game Henry halfhead you play
as half ahead
that's it that's the game but it's so
much more than that too because you see
Henry can be many things can be anything
in fact he has the Curious ability to be
able to transform into anything he can
reach using this peculiar power and
perplexing form you'll live the life of
the Title Character navigating sandbox
situations crafted by zurich-based
developers lululu entertainment and in
so doing maybe Ponder the philosophical
questions
who is how is
what does it mean to be Henry halfhead
welcome may I introduce you to Henry
Henry's not just anyone if they're
anything there well everything Henry can
transform into everything in their reach
yes everything and that's how they
manage their daily life
the familiar noise of Henry's alarm
clock announces the dawn of a new day
and it will keep ringing until Henry
gets up and calms the nervous quivering
machine
[Music]
hit at least half awake Henry is ready
for their morning routine which they
usually start by making their bed
staying in bed is tempting but only
leads to regret later Henry knows that
if you want to change the world you have
to start off by making your own bed
completing this simple task in the
morning gives Henry a little bit of
Pride and the feeling of control over
their life
with part of the morning routine done
Henry was ready to freshen up
[Music]
thank you
for hours Henry could sit there lifting
the seat up and down pretending it was a
singing mouth
not too hot not too cold
Henry bought a turmeric soap they didn't
know they just like the color it's
actually great for their skin
that got all the dirt and we should now
dried themselves
and dry Henry is now ready for a proper
breakfast
with a warm beverage is important and so
is keeping up with the news
have a wonderful day
[Music]
the best drink Henry can make from Beans
candy of nature delicious
well fed and well-informed Henry has to
get ready and pack for work
[Music]
if Henry takes The Lunchbox and leaves
now they can catch the eight o'clock bus
the Henry double the fun
play Henry's not so ordinary everyday
life in court mode
Henry everyday life with a Twist
okay
our next game is from Yepi Carlson a
Creator who's perhaps best well known
for his work as Master puzzle Creator on
limbo and inside
we have the honor of working with him to
publish two of his solo projects as part
of double fine presents Rhythm action
platformer 140 and Co-op arcade shooter
Thoth two of the most fiendishly
well-designed and fun puzzle games I've
ever played that truly give you a sense
for an appreciation of yepi's
contributions to those play dead titles
his new game sees him teaming back up
Jakob Schmidt composer of 140 and
applying his trademark puzzle skills to
a beautiful mind-bending Adventure game
this is cocoon
hello I'm janop co-founder and audio
director of geometric interactive in
Copenhagen I would like to show you what
our amazing team has been working on for
the last couple of years our game cocoon
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
cocoon is an adventure game with
multiple worlds and each of these worlds
are contained within an orb
[Music]
let me demonstrate by jumping out of the
world which we are currently exploring
just like that we are now in a world
outside
the orange orb here contains the world
we were previously exploring
this jump out one more time
we are now in a world even further
outside
and can explore this world using the
orange orb that we picked up
orbs can be placed on switches to power
devices and solve puzzles
um
and you can even throw them into pipes
[Music]
you can use the hierarchy of Worlds
within worlds to solve interesting
puzzles
for example
safely avoid this moving barrier
to jump out of the world
let it pass by
and jump back in
now cocoon is not only about exploration
and parcels
within each world you have to face a
mighty Guardian
here is a first glimpse of one of these
encounters
thank you
foreign
we hope you look forward to exploring
the mysterious worlds of cocoon
releasing later this year on Steam Xbox
PlayStation and Nintendo switch
thank you
and now I'm pleased to bring you a title
from French Canadian developer
impossible in this relaxing artistic
exploration game you play a painter with
a watercolor brush and a whole city to
explore this game is more than
appropriate for Day of the devs summer
game Fest Edition because its title ete
in French translates to the word summer
hi my name is laglo and I'm the creative
director at impossible we are a small
Montreal based in the studio working on
our first Idol ete
in anything you see the world through
the eyes of a painter with every surface
acting like a blank canvas just waiting
for you to fill it with color
Ife means summer in French because it's
set in our french-speaking hometown of
Mojo Canada as you step into the shoes
of a painter who's traveling abroad for
well a summer this is a game for people
who love pure exploration your freedom
open City scenes at your own pace
following your curiosity getting
sidetracked and discovering Secrets
along the way
when you fill something with paint
you'll extract its color as droplets of
experience and as you level up you'll
become able to unleash larger splashes
of paint that reveal a bigger part of
the world at once
foreign
taking part in their lighthearted
everyday anecdotes and some of them will
even commission artworks from you
using your bike you can travel quickly
back to your apartment and paint those
commissions on canvas
[Music]
that's where your creativity comes into
play
at your easel you can create gorgeous
watercolor artworks using anything
you've discovered in your Expedition so
far
steps on your canvas can be freely moved
resized rotated in 3D and even recolored
the canvas is pretty much your sandbox
that lets you put your own spin on
commissions and if you're feeling
inspired you can paint as many creative
artworks as you like without any kind of
limitation
with hundreds of unlockable stamps at
your disposal and dozens of commissions
to inspire you the only limit really is
your imagination
apart from living your best life as the
friendly neighborhood painter you'll
also get to meet other like-minded
artists like Mayan an ambitious
photographer and Theo a talented
musician among many others
if you manage to befriend them maybe
they'll let you in on their best gift
secret an abandoned building that could
become your very own painting Studio
but you'll have to dive into that story
for yourself it is coming out in 2024
and we hope you'll enjoy your adventures
as a traveling painter in this lovingly
crafted Whimsical summer world
hi everybody how are you liking the show
so far this is the time where we take a
brief break to talk about the long and
complicated process by which we accept
games into the nominating committee and
all the legal ramifications and the
technical rules that go with the
accounting of the Tim sorry I thought
that yeah I thought I was doing
something here too
all right
hey Kelly from Indie Mega Booth here
with a very exciting announcement
we're back
[Music]
if you're a fan of Indie Games you may
have seen the Indie Mega booth at shows
like Pax West and PAX East over the last
decade bringing together a curated
selection of the best up-and-coming
Indie titles
games like Crypt of the necrodancer
tunic disco Elysium
Spirit fairer Celeste mini Metro
astroneer The Stanley Parable and papers
please have all been part of the Indie
Mega Booth Community if you're a Dev
you'll likely know us from our industry
work such as our GDC showcases our
presence at bit Summit are Global
Outreach and events including a robust
scholarship and grant program and if
you've never heard of any of this well
that's fine just think of us as like a
stepping stone into the games industry
where folks who love Indie Games can
connect with each other discover new
games and be part of a welcoming diverse
broad creative Community
Indie Mega booth has been in hibernation
during the pandemic but we are so
excited to announce that we're finally
waking up from our big long Slumber and
we're ready to move forward with IMB 2.0
head on over to our brand new website
indiemegaboost.com MB ND no by signing
up for our newsletter learn about new
games upcoming showcases digital sales
and the best ways to help support the
games and developers that you know and
love as we've always said individually
we're tiny together we're Mega
foreign
we have another world premiere for you
all and it's also really thematically
appropriate for this showcase uh you'll
see why in a second uh it's from the
aesthetically amazing studio called
lanency uh they're famous for the alto
series that you know and love but this
next one is not what you're expecting
from them uh it'll be hurting your way
it'll be flocking your way
no I like hurting
it'll be hurting your way next year it's
called Summerhill
about sheep
hi there my name is Harry Nesbitt and
I'm the founder and creative director of
land and sea we're a small team from the
UK best known as the developers of the
Altus Adventure series
now over the last few years we've been
busy growing the team and laying the
groundwork for our most ambitious
project yet it's an entirely new IP that
aims to build on the themes that we care
about most as a studio and we're super
excited to be able to share this
exclusive first teaser with you today so
please take a look and I'll be back at
the end to tell you more
foreign
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed this first look at
our brand new game Summer Hill
to give you a little bit more detail
Simon Hill is a story driven puzzle game
in which you play as a young Shepherd
and their dog
together you'll be setting out to rescue
your lost flock that have been scattered
across the mysterious land the lies of
the border of your home
Summer Hill brings together gentle
problem solving fluid herding-based
gameplay and striking pastoral
Landscapes to tell a Timeless Coming of
Age folktale as a team we've been
massively inspired by the rich history
and cultural impact of sheep herding
across the world there are a few people
or places that haven't been impacted in
some small way by the practice of
sharpening even the name Summit Hill is
a name often given to Highland passages
where sheep are taken to Graves during
the warmest months of the year
in many ways sheep herding is in our DNA
and we really want to do justice to this
Timeless tradition and tell a story that
could only be told in this way
we're also super excited to be working
again with our longtime collaborator
Todd Baker Todd is a composer and audio
designer best known for his work on
games such as Monument Valley 2 dreams
and our very own artist Odyssey
we can't wait to share more with you so
if you'd like to be the first to hear
about what we're up to please head over
to our steam page to wishlist the game
or go to Summit Hill dog game to join
our mailing list thanks again and we
look forward to sharing more with you
again soon
next up we have an update on eternites
this is from Studio Sai essentially a
one-person team with a few friends
helping out on the side and it's a
dating action game now you've heard a
lot about this title uh sorry
what's happening
I'm sorry Greg I know I shouldn't be
interrupting day of the devs
but it's urgent
a virus has turned most of us into
I don't know how much longer we can hold
out
it won't be easy and the road will be
long but who knows
maybe we'll find one more thing Worth
Fighting For
turnip is a dating action game that
takes adrenaline fuel combat and mixes
it together with a heartfelt love story
can I be honest for a moment
with all these infected
it's too much
and it's during these moments that I'm
happy to have someone to lean on
Our Lives holding puzzles exploring
dungeons it all seems easier when you
have someone special by your side
to make things less scary
Oh
what now
did you just shush me
[Music]
but you might hear us
hey
have you ever passed a note to your
crush
I mean or you you can just fight for
friendship that's cool and not
wow we are so cheesy
games we have so many mini games that
can help you unlock unique skills and
spells in battle
so yeah you can fight monsters explore
dungeons
to date
I mean so many things like train
scavenge dance
twice anyway you have to manage and
balance all these activities if you want
to save the world the clock is ticking
okay cool bye
wish list now
next up from Italian Icelandic developer
evil licorice comes a Nostalgia fueled
Gadget building Sim that demystifies
Electronics engineering and allows you
to share your creations with the
community hello everyone I'm Marco
bangali from Evil Licorice and I'm one
of the designers of retro gadgets
although it takes me forever to build
something like this I love the feeling
of seeing something happening on a
screen like this one when I rotate the
knob or I press the buttons and this is
where the idea for retro gadgets comes
from is to being able to build digital
gadgets with little effort
We Love pico8 by Lexa love because it
brings you this retro environment where
you can build your own games in Lua and
we also love shenzhenayo by Electronics
because it managed to teach you
low-level programming effortlessly and
retro gadgets tries to take the Best of
Both Worlds and adds a layer of Hardware
building and customization all this is
packaged in a cozy and retro inspired
environment
[Music]
we have a fantastic community and people
have been creating insane gadgets that
go well beyond our initial expectations
so please join our disco server and
check them out retro gadgets is in Early
Access on Steam and we have big plans in
store
bye
if you've ever watched the Mars
Curiosity Rover on one of its missions
you very well may have become fascinated
by one of the hyper-specific
Contraptions and gadgets it keeps on
board to measure soil samples and hunt
for traces of water our next game poses
a very important question though sure
curiosity can tell us that whether on a
planet millions of miles away but can it
deliver a pizza
in Mars first Logistics from shape shop
you'll be giving the task of carrying
awkwardly shaped objects from point A to
point B by assembling and piloting your
very own Mars rovers and in doing so
perhaps you will solve a pepperoni-based
problems that truly matter
hello I'm Ian McLarty from shape shop
we're a small team based in Melbourne
Australia and we're making this game
Mars first Logistics
in Mars first Logistics you'll be
helping to establish a colony on the
surface of Mars you'll do this by
transporting often awkwardly shaped
objects between A and B using vehicles
that you design and build yourself
as you complete deliveries the game will
give you new toys to play with
[Music]
thank you
the game is set in a vast open world and
you're free to pick and choose which
jobs you'd like to take on
there's a mix of procedurally generated
side jobs and handcrafted main contracts
in the main contracts you'll be helping
to construct new buildings in the games
world
[Music]
one of the main challenges in the game
is figuring out how to pick up each item
and deliver it safely to its destination
using the parts that you have available
foreign
[Music]
parts
more creative options will become
available to you
and I think a lot of the fun in the game
is just messing around and being
creative in its editor
[Music]
and finally I'm really excited to
announce that myerspace Logistics will
be launching into steam Early Access on
the 22nd of June it's just two weeks
away and we're really looking forward to
seeing what everyone builds in the game
thank you
you'd think the aftermath of a worldwide
flood would be pretty bleak right well
UK and Denmark based Studio D guten
fabric has a different take from the
studio that brought you mitazione and
Sports Friends comes the all-new
Adventure set in the sprawling
post-flood world of saltsee the
adventure unfolds differently with every
decision so there's always something new
to see in your next playthrough
so buckle your swatches and get ready
for the world premiere of the stylish
seaworthy salt sea Chronicles
I'm Hannah nicklin from DQ to fabric and
we made salt sea Chronicles
we're super stoked to show you the world
premiere of salty Chronicles today it's
a flooded World story driven Adventure
game where you play as a ship's whole
crew
[Music]
thank you
at the beginning of the game you're
going to discover that Maya your captain
has gone missing and together your
ragtag crew are going to host a ship and
set out across the saltza archipelago in
search of Clues
in each chapter of the game you decide
where to head next who to explore with
from the crew when you get there and
what to say to the people that you meet
along the way
salty Chronicles unique art style is
brought to life by beautiful animation
and each location is built on the
fragments of this world that came before
our art team have really done an
incredible job
one of my favorite locations is called
Los Gatos and on that island the people
there live symbiotically with this
community of cats
as you explore you'll find a brand new
trick taking card game designed
especially for the world of salty it's a
really good way to sort of take a break
from the story it's called spoils and
you can play it all over the archipelago
and you might discover how each
Community has slightly different house
rules
another thing we're super proud of is
our exploration system so we're sort of
done away with the Walk of Shame in
adventure games so if you miss a clue
instead of sort of slowly tricks into
the other end of the island you're just
going to tap the shoulder button on your
controller or select your screen span
Arrow to move almost instantaneously
across a space it allows us to lay the
story down away from a linear path much
more organically
salty Chronicles doesn't tell a story
about a hero it's a story about a
community and how you navigate the world
together and each community that you
meet in turn is going to be rich and
amusing and strange maybe and have its
own things going on
there's also a strong sense of genre
based storytelling too so while you
might be new to the world of salty
you'll know that you're in a Scooby-Doo
chapter or a Romeo and Juliet chapter or
a detective one
there are plenty of laughs but tough
choices and meaningful moments too our
writer's room of award-winning
storytellers have done an incredible job
we're so delighted to share salsi
Chronicles with you all today and I
can't wait for you to explore the rich
World get to know the wonderful
characters and to hear what paths you
chart when you play
[Music]
all right this next game it sorry
Tim keeps texting let's see
oh Tim wants me to read something
apologies but this seems important uh
the thing I love most about day of the
devs
says Tim as me as Tim I don't know is
getting to know all these amazing game
developers I love hearing them describe
their games and their creative process
but I wish I could hear more I wish I
could be a fly on the wall ease dropping
all their private conversations all
their ups and downs their triumphs and
tribulations while making a real video
game over the course of seven years too
bad there's no way to do it or is there
this is actually pretty cool two-player
Productions was embedded with double
fine for the course of seven years while
they were making Psychonauts 2 and they
made a Super Hyper duper long
documentary series unlike anything
you've ever seen in games all the
intimacy all the tears the outrage and
joys and and all the things that happen
in game development that never really
gets documented because who has access
like this so here's a very quick sneak
peek at their incredibly long series we
highly encourage you to watch this thing
it's it's amazing
so what's next
to get to the dollar amount we're
talking about it's probably going to
take financing from a lot of different
Avenues
[Music]
whenever grasshop is going to start
Tim's is going to start taking our
people
so there's a ton of stuff going on right
now it's kind of breaking me but you
know it's fun it'll be really rewarding
when it's done
hopefully you get a chance to work on
Psychonauts game in the near future
[Music]
thank you for helping us bring
all right
[Music]
to submit your game for future day of
the devs or to just hear about day of
the devs in general go to daythedevs.com
for more info thank you to all the
incredible sponsors that have been with
us since the very beginnings of day of
the devs we're going on 11 years we
could not pay for any of this without
these sponsors they they donate to us
ask for nothing in return except to
Showcase some incredible games from
Indie devs all around the world so
please Applause for all the cool logos
on the screen we appreciate you we
couldn't do this without you thank you
thank you again to the incomparable dose
one uh he's been supplying the Beats for
all the transitions between all these
amazing games ever since we started
doing these digital showcases for Day of
the depths uh thank you again you're a
hero amongst Heroes go go check out his
music it's amazing just one is
incredible thank you for watching day of
the devs yet again if you're looking for
more information or you just want to
subscribe to the coolest newsletter in
all the land go to dayofthedevs.com the
URL on your screen follow us on social
media we got more coming up this year
thank you to our friend Jeff Keeley the
summer game Fest showcase was amazing
we're so happy to be a part of Summer
game Fest for these last many years
definitely stick around we're not
completely done yet we have a musical
performance featuring the sounds of New
Caledonia thanks to our friends who made
the game Shia it's worth it it's really
cool happening right now
met tonight
[Music]
thank you
I love you
[Music]
foreign
because
[Music]
thank you